buenas tardes quiero que me levantes la
mano si adolescente no te sentías
escuchado por tus padres
hay un error común que comete la
sociedad es decir que los jóvenes somos
el presente somos el futuro cuando en
realidad somos el presente yo tengo
quince minutos para demostrarte lo
yo pertenezco a tony dominios nos
importa una plataforma web de debate
juvenil que busca lograr que la voz de
los jóvenes sea escuchada
usualmente nos dicen que los jóvenes
hablamos es puras tonterías
pero en realidad estamos en contacto con
temas como la homofobia feminismo entre
otros tantos temas
frente a esto nos dicen que no tenemos
una opinión formada con la mayoría de
los casos y es por esto que nosotros
identificamos tres tipos de relaciones
con los adultos y los jóvenes
la primera es una relación en donde el
joven ya no busca expresarse porque no
cree que los jóvenes lo vayan a escuchar
no creen que su opinión pueda cambiar
algo
la segunda es una charla una charla
entre ellos en donde el adulto busca
conseguir que los jóvenes expresen pero
los jóvenes no lo hacen
y la tercera y a la cual nosotros
apostamos es una relación de diálogo
donde tu opinión no sea más o menos
importante es por tu edad
hace poco leí en una página web que el
gran desafío de esta sociedad actual es
la generación desencantada
una generación de muertos envía dicen
que esa generación somos nosotros
lamentablemente yo les voy a decir que
si existe esta generación
esta generación de muertos envía como
nos llaman se desencantó con la vida
dicen que la tecnología nos sacó todo
poder de iniciativa nos encerró a
nosotros mismos y nos sacó la esperanza
en el futuro
si existe pero necesitamos ayuda para
volver a encantarnos porque es muy fácil
contagiar el desencanto pero contagia el
encanto no es un trabajo dormías y eso
es lo que nosotros apuntamos a que los
jóvenes se vuelvan a encantar porque
somos una generación necesaria
importante y decisiva para las
generaciones futuras y pasadas
el futuro es nuestro pero también
ustedes que nos tienen que ayudar
una vez que les conté el porque creo que
ya están en condiciones de escuchar el
cómo
como ya dije anteriormente vamos a
hacerlo a través de una plataforma
donde mensualmente los integrantes de
toning vamos a aportar un tema y para
que nos digan que los jóvenes hablamos
por hablar vamos a poner información
sobre dicho tema para tener opiniones
formadas que es la principal crítica que
se nos hace que los jóvenes no tenemos
una opinión formada porque somos jóvenes
y no podemos opinar
en esta plataforma a través de ingresar
en tu usuario no se te va a juzgar por
tu edad ni por tu sexo no se van a tener
en cuenta temas banales cómo se podrían
decir se va a tener en cuenta tu opinión
tu opinión más seria escuchada
seguramente se preguntarán una
plataforma por qué
todos tenemos acceso a la magra mayoría
hoy en día estamos en pleno siglo 21
todos estamos conectados todos o la gran
mayoría
en esta plataforma en pleno siglo 21
buscamos conseguir llegar a la gran
mayoría de jóvenes sabemos que no vamos
a poder hacerlo a todos porque es un
trabajo dormidas
vamos a empezar con nuestro círculo más
cercano y desde allí expandirnos pero es
necesaria la ayuda de todos para
transformar este mundo que recibimos y
que le dejaremos a las fondas a las
generaciones futuras
no somos una generación desencantada
somos una generación que necesita ayuda
para volver a encantar gracias
[Aplausos]